welcome back to cbs this morning there
are new questions about how police
handle
mental health calls following disturbing
video of a sheriff's deputy
restraining an 18 year old the deputy
was responding to a 9-1-1
call that the teenager nakaya trigg was
jumping in front of cars and threatening
suicide
but she was not doing either when he
approached her
our national correspondent jerica duncan
spoke with the teenager's mother hi
jerica good morning good morning the
teenager's mother as you all can imagine
is highly upset by this
the kaufman county sheriff's department
is conducting an internal investigation
the deputy
is currently on administrative leave but
the family says
he deserves to be fired after what they
say was an assault on nikaya trigg
and are questioning why he responded in
the first place
we want to warn you some of the video
you're about to see is disturbing
what's wrong newly released body cam
footage shows a sheriff's deputy
only identified as martin following a
barefoot 18 year old nakaya trigg
as she was walking home last tuesday
what's your address
the sheriff's office had received calls
about a young lady in the neighborhood
attempting suicide by jumping into
oncoming traffic
they're a young lady an african-american
lady that is walking in the middle of
the street
i'm keeping an eye on her because i
don't want her anything to happen to her
three people have already had the swerve
out of the way in
me including the situation escalates
when martin tries to stop the visibly
upset teen
from walking away we got a call that you
were jumping out in front of cars
[Music]
martin's body camera falls to the ground
but for more than two minutes the
officer is on top of trigg
[Applause]
i can't breathe
she was probably afraid that she was
about to be arrested or worse he's
expecting a person who
is in a crisis to be able to calm down
and follow commands
and i don't know how realistic that is
lisa daly is with the treatment advocacy
center
she says people with mental health
concerns are at higher risk of dying
when interacting with police
what do you think could have been done
differently you can have first
responders
that are not police or that the police
are available but they aren't the
primary response
so you might have somebody who's really
trained
and de-escalate the sheriff's office
says martin was
following protocol adding that in an
effort to prevent the female from
running into traffic
or sustaining an injury deputy martin
executed a control technique taught by
the kaufman county sheriff's office
it's called a top mount and is commonly
used in jiu jitsu and allows the deputy
to control the lower body without
impeding breathing
nikki ray is nakia's mother if that is
their statement
that would have been a move that he
would have needed to do when she was
still on the main road
attempting to run in front of cars when
he got out of his vehicle and approached
my daughter
she was on the sidewalk and about to
cross the street
headed home when she arrived on scene
she heard her daughter saying
she couldn't breathe do you wonder what
would have happened had you not gotten
there sooner
that is one thing that i don't even want
to think about why does she need a
handcuff
triggg was taken to the hospital for a
mental health evaluation
and released 15 minutes later according
to her mother
if someone is in mental distress law
enforcement
people who are trained to respond to
criminal activity
should not be those who respond to
someone who is in mental distress
kim t cole is the family's attorney and
echoes daily's concerns
about law enforcement and situations
involving mental health
they do not have the training for it
they're called out when someone has
broken the law
this is not the same as a teenage girl
who is having an emotional moment
when trey complained that the handcuffs
were too tight ray could not
understand why the deputy handcuffed her
daughter in the first place
she says she reached to rub her
daughter's wrist to calm her down
but police say ray struck the deputy the
video
is not clear as to exactly what happened
but ray has been charged with assault on
a public servant and interference
with public duties another concern for
ray
she says she got a call from the
sheriff's office that deputy martin
tested positive for covey oh that's like
deputy martin who was on top of her
daughter exactly
has her daughter been tested yet her
daughter has been tested um the mother's
results came in
they're negative she's still awaiting
her daughter's uh results
but this is you know we covered these
stories all the time
and and it's you're thankful that we
have the video
yeah so that we can ask those questions
you know this is under investigation and
and the officers on administrative leave
i'm thankful i'm so glad that the girl
is alive
but i don't understand why in
hindsight's 20 20 why he didn't just
walk behind her and just see where she's
going she's clearly upset she's clearly
upset
and afraid this is a perfect example of
a case
where you need someone who has better
training to respond
right there was never an allegation that
she was violent no
toward herself or anyone else and the
fact that the mother was trying to
de-escalate the situation that shouldn't
be her job but she was very aware of the
optics
and she got down to the same level as
that deputy to say what's going on
the use of handcuffs is just
inexplicable i think a lot can be
learned here thank you jericho